si dans moins de six mois monsieur
musique n'a pas rempli le lapi avec un
nouvel artiste
il cédera sa place de directeur pour son
troisième film fabrice éboué et nicolas
un producteur un peu à la ramasse en
manque de résultats il monte un groupe
avec un prêtre un rabbin un imam la
certaine ressemblance avec le trio de
prêtres chanteurs est assumée et
pourquoi on ne fait pas ça un traître et
un humain et une gueule jim le départ en
fait je voulais faire une parodie de
cette tournée là parce que ça
m'intéressait je trouve ça amusant des
prêtres deviennent des sortes de rock
star c'était le mot aux antipodes les
deux la religion pour moi c'était juste
un prétexte pour que les trois bras
cassés se rencontrent et finalement la
seule religion qui vont avoir c'est ce
qui va les faire marcher ensemble c'est
la musique mais loin d'en faire une
satire religieuse fabrice éboué a voulu
que coexister soit avant tout une
critique de la société d'aujourd'hui
c'était plus parler d'un groupe fabrique
et pour un succès pour parler de ce que
ce soit l'humour où la musique
aujourd'hui on appartient tous à des
grands groupes qui font aussi bien
effectivement de la charcuterie que de
la lingerie que de la musique ou du
comique le 24 septembre dernier la
tournée de promotion a fait un arrêt à
saint quentin en yvelines pour plutôt
une bonne approche
en fait forcément de points de vue qui
sont différents mais tous avec toujours
une certaine légèreté et c'est vrai que
c'est assez bluffant de se dire que des
fois faut pas grand chose pour rire
ensemble tu assez souvent cinéma et ça
faisait longtemps que j'avais paris
comme ça un film et je trouvais que le
thème était intéressant les messages
sont intéressants et c'est vrai que
c'est une histoire plutôt d'hommes
d'hommes qui se rencontrent avec une
très belle très belle histoire et les
sentiments la fin les aventures du
groupe co existent et sont à découvrir
en salles le 11 octobre pour exister
quelque chose qui voulait à la
communauté juive à moi c'est rapide